i was told that everyone who works at
the tva was created by the timekeepers
that's ridiculous they're all variants
just like us
they don't know that i'm ovarian
welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode 3 doomed loki and sylvie on the
dying planet
of lamentus one but reveal that everyone
at the tva is a freaking variant
which of course has us asking wait damn
it this is inside marvel new rockstars
loki after show
i'm mt eric is off this week but don't
worry his easter egg breakdown of
episode 3 will hit new rock stars on
friday but for now with me here today to
discuss
everything that happened in episode
three of loki is of course the wonderful
and lovely jessica clemens what's going
on jess how do you do
when we said wait a damn minute together
we could easily have our own radio show
[Laughter]
these fools will not stop talking about
loki being bisexual
um i'm so excited this episode is so fun
and i'm so excited to finally to like
jump into it the first two episodes
also really like you explore a lot but
now we're actually getting into like
okay we know what's happening here's the
backstory for people
and yes i'm very honored to be on
episode three because it got crazier
just when you thought you knew just when
you thought you knew that's what you
thought you knew they flipped you never
know
you don't know nothing with the tba
because the timekeepers are a bunch of
liars
they are there are i still i like them
so much now
which is the problem i've always been
rooting for a villain i like villains
because they have
such good like justifications so i'm so
excited to see what the tva's like
ultimate justification is and who is in
on it and who isn't it on it but anyway
in this episode sylvie the alias chosen
by the female loki variant constructs
false memories in the mind of c20
and she breaks into the tva to try to
get to the time keepers but fights loki
and runs into red slayer and then loki
temp pads them off to lamentus 1
a doomed moon on a collision course with
another planet and then their temp ad
runs low on battery so they plot to
charge it in the arc evacuation shuttle
and then they talk about love they fight
with the guards on the train and then
get thrown off
literally like tossed off breaking the
temp pad completely and then sylvia
reveals that the tva agents are also
variants which is literally
insane and amazing and you know i was
kind of suspecting that but whatever
and then they try to hijack the ark off
of the planet but you know
a meteor destroys it and you know stops
their plans which is very shocking
and unfortunate so of course we're going
to talk about this bombshell reveal that
the tva are all variants but
before we get into all that make sure to
go right now to new rockstarsmerch.com
like right now go i mean it so you can
check out our latest obsession shirt
loki out of time there is a limited
supply so when they're all gone they are
gone
forever forever there's an entire loki
collection in other loki shirts
including
the augmented reality shirt loki prince
cell phone cases
miss minutes stickers which is the best
part and a miss minutes wall clock which
might be better than the stickers now
that i think about it but whatever and
when you buy a loki out of time shirt
you get the ability to write an
additional custom shout out that will
appear
at the bottom of the screen shout outs
like one from joel zabarrus who asked
do you think the series will end with
the unraveling of the sacred timeline
into the multiverse of madness uh yeah
i would say so what do you think jess uh
uh yeah i would hope it's not going to
be fixed anytime soon it is not going to
go back to
one branch and another question from
greg alba our friends at
real redirects who who says soul ruler
eternal ruler i'm assuming he's talking
about loki so you know what you're right
bro
you're right you're right also uh you
have a nice head of hair i i can't
relate
anyway and and one from david
stattler who asked what is your favorite
marvel character and why is it loki
who is your favorite marvel character
jess my favorite character's vision
me too oh my god no one ever says that
this is my favorite it's weird for
someone that has
so much like mental illness to be like
yeah the robot the one that has
everything basically figured out is my
favorite character um but i just think
that
the spin-off comics and his normal
comics were the best and he has so much
and so he's my favorite and then
and then of course scarlet witch of
course you gotta you gotta
garnish i gotta love this i love vision
i love vision because he's just a nice
boy oh he's just a nice boy
but again check out all these options at
newrockstarsmerch.com but okay jess hit
me with that first question
okay here i go my time to shine
don't mess this up wait a damn minute
if the tpa agents are all past variants
what was mobius's past renslayer's past
and miss minutes passed and how did they
even get there
this is a this is a thorough question
question that is question of this
episode so let's start with mobius okay
so mobius
i think he could be loki that's just my
main theory
and i'm not gonna go too much into that
because like it's it's just my crazy
person rambling well no
you're getting more and more closer to
it being loki i think
the only reason why i want to say it's
not loki is there's so much going on
which isn't a really good excuse
um they just have so many characters and
to like put this one in there also but
the show is based on his variants
so i think you i i'm
i'm gonna say i am more on this train
than i was on the mephisto train and i
was
hard on the mephisto train so i took my
hat
i can take an l you guys i i take some
form of humility easily
i'm i'ma i'm taking the misfesto l2
because i was right there with eric
i was oh i was with it with it so much i
try not to bring it up as much today
but the loki one is proving itself to be
more valid
my only thing is because i've been on
rogue theory so much i was rereading a
lot of the
uh the 2010 issues of loki and i was
like
wouldn't it be fun if he was if they did
bring in like balder
um his brother oh my god i've been and
he's wondering where the hell balder is
in the mcu
this entire time would it be too much
would it be too much to put him in
i was like but no because we don't he
wasn't really
like you mean like as a mobius variant
yeah so if mobius is variant
if moby is a variant of balder um
or if we used to be a thor variant oh
that would see
that would be fun that would be crazy
that would be nuts
i would like i just don't want him to be
another ralph boner
i don't want him to be just like some
random dude that likes jet skis
he's like hi my name is hugh jass i'm
like
that would be kind of funny but i just
want him to be more than like
just some dad at a barbecue that just
always like jet skis
i feel like they have to be bad not bad
people necessarily but people that got
eliminated or whatever it's what is it
called when they'd
oh reset when they reset people they're
just resetting their memory
and then forcing them to be in the tva
so it must be those people that are
being like
all those resets all those people that
get like sentenced to like oh
because they're so quick to sentence you
immediately they have to be like
you're sentenced and then like when they
go and you think you're dead you
actually were
it's like being resurrected and you
don't know your memory and now you're in
the tv
wild that would be such an interesting
way to do it it's like hey we're
we're literally like zapping employees
into existence it's like yeah
now you're an employee you're an
employer
is he just teasing people as they walk
by them basically you saw how many
people work there
who tells the librarian like what is
going on
apparently and according to all these
mcdonald's drive-throughs nobody wants
to work anymore so you got to
disintegrate them into the workforce
it's just burning people to death but no
i i mobius i i'm on your i'm on your
side i do think
it's loki and if you're wrong we're all
wrong
let's let's all be wrong together but i
i just feel like all the cinematography
i think you're right i think you're
right so that's mobius
it could be loki how about rent slayer
what like so we see that she has a pen
from franklin d roosevelt high school in
episode two i believe
um so do you think that she could be a
teacher from franklin
oh that'd be fun that'd be fun i just
really assumed wren slayer knows that
she's rent slayer
she works too close to the time like the
uh
the time keepers to be like and senses
too many people to
death to know that like to not know
so i think oh so she knows who she is
and she's like i prefer this life
other than the one that i'm a villain in
um
and so i thought i just assumed she knew
but i liked the theory
of course because of rogue theory i love
the theory that she's a teacher that'd
be kind of cute
but she's really mean if she's a teacher
hey i mean some teachers be mean you
know
like it's not uncommon to have a mean
teacher
they pop up sometimes yeah she was it
also
it stuck with me for some reason in the
beginning of this episode when she was
when
um sylvie was like i'm going to kill
step back where i'm going to kill loki
and she's like go ahead i don't care i
was like i don't give a
i was like that's some villain tendency
right there she truly does not care
about this man she wants
to be damn yeah she's like go ahead that
gets rid of one of my problems
seriously like in episode two she was
just like yo loki is really annoying and
i kind of don't want to be dealing with
them anymore so yeah she killed loki
she'd be like yeah she probably now i
guess it'll be five dollars
yeah okay like thank you for for doing
my job
she probably would and that's why she
wants him stretching this is me reaching
why she'd rather have him dead than
reset
because she probably knows that if he's
resetted that he's going to be coming
back as a variant
um detective or whatever also i feel
like if anyone saw the physical loki i
guess he doesn't have to
he could be in a different timeline but
if you see loki even if he lost all his
memory you'd be like this is
the god of mischief why is he working at
the tva this person is dangerous
this is true i feel like loki's made a
big enough name for himself so that you
could just be like oh there
he is a little uh troublemaker
mcguinness but that's how i feel about
ren's lair that's how i feel about red
slayer
that's renssler but what about casey the
nice man who knows nothing about fish
apparently
you know yes
i mean like is the reason why he doesn't
know what fish are is because like i
don't know he drowned in an aquarium or
something and the tva wiped his memory
of that
of being drowned who knows or maybe
he could have been a fish in his you
know past life before he got his memory
erased because we are getting
neymar and atlantis and all that stuff
so like
maybe it's that oh
i don't know i'm just going off the fish
angle from what we know of
think about it kc k c
k the letter c kang
the conqueror casey could be kang
you never know this is if this is like
right theory
i would you know
that could be the twist just you never
know like if tracy is secretly king like
a kang variant
it would be the stupidest thing of all
time but like such a huge twist
i would love to see if it would rather
not it be the you know the intern
but i would love it to be uh mobius as
king the conqueror but
as we saw in the news it doesn't seem
like he's gonna be actually making an
appearance in loki
but also that is some bat thinking
yeah i don't know that's what my brain
went i'm like casey
when you kept saying casey i could be
like casey in the sunshine band i don't
know
where are you going with this i hope we
see what i
i think definitely are going to show
everyone's past lives
but i really hope it add casey to those
people on the list
maybe it'll be like how in one division
where they put everyone's name on a
board and you knew what their names were
and who they were in that town
they'll do something like that where you
see like this person was a bus driver
this person and now he's shooting aliens
right but yeah hopefully i hope i hope
casey is secretly a badass like it'd
just be so funny
it would just it would be great and oh
that would makes more sense and that's
why he's so like
like good jelly boy now like
literally and also like he's literally
collecting infinity stones i mean like i
know that everybody in the tva is doing
that but like
we're going to get into a conscious
thing there anyway
i have something about those infinity
stones we're going to get into it we're
going to get into it in a second
okay okay but what about miss minutes
what do you like do you think that she
could be a variant because like
she could be the very first program
she's a literally
that's a visual image yeah she's
literally
just like the clippit of the tva i don't
know if you guys know about clipping
but like back in the day we back in uh
you know like the 90s and oh
there's microsoft word
um there used to be a little uh avatar a
paper clip called clipit and used to
help us whenever he had problems
so like i think that miss minutes could
be a little like uh
you know like a siri or like you're
you're just your ai
helper which is why we have like a
little miss minutes button on the
elevator we have miss
this minutes button on the temp pads
it's just like hey if you need help
press this we're probably secretly
watching you at the same time but
whatever
what if there's a place in the tva that
is like
hidden or um off the map or whatever for
everyone that works there
but they eventually break into it and
miss minutes has like a section where
she explains the negative
things that the tva has done but in the
at the time okay so the tva is
all knowing the longest running thing on
the planet right so
in the universe so what if
they at one point were like oh it's okay
for tva agents to know this
but now that they're all variants
they're like oh they shouldn't know this
so there's this like old prehistoric
part of the tva
that we don't see yet and we'll probably
see later on first version of the tv
yeah and it'll be like they get there
and then it like sparks and it goes
it's miss minutes being like when the
world needed our help we came
and now we're destroying everyone or
something like crazy
um maybe we'll get something like that
but i also just think that miss minutes
is just uh
just an ai just an ai but not an ai
in the sense that vision is an ai yeah
yeah
okay but yeah i really like that idea
like just like there's just like a
another tva or like an older tva that
was taken over
by this new current version of the tva i
feel like variants couldn't always have
been
the workers of the tva i feel like they
just found out eventually they're like
you know what works like this weird
labor the slave labor
let's make it work it's basically the
prison industry so
they just like started making other
workers work like this
the truth disney thought they were slick
but they're just
literally mapping the prison industry
[Laughter]
no actually now that you bring this up
like the the idea of prisons makes sense
to me because
all of these variants could technically
be i mean if the timekeepers are even
telling the truth
prisoners of the timekeeper war the
multiversal war
oh dude it absolutely is oh
no you're right
every war has you know prisoners and
like you know like uh
damn after effects so it's like all
these people
could have just been fighting the
timekeepers and that's what and then
they lost
that's what sylvie's coming back for
that's what sylvie was uh
what if sylvie was a variant timekeeper
like cop and then she was the one that
got out of it because she's low-key
she has the the power to go in to break
into people's minds you think she can't
break into her own mind or even like put
up a wall that makes you think you reset
her but she actually didn't
and that's why she's trying to kill the
time variance authority oh boom
there you go right here everybody
we figured it out no need to watch loki
anymore yeah even if that isn't the
scenario that's still a great scenario
for me
i love that i would be happy with that
100 100 oh my god
baby but hopefully this entire season
ends
with all of these characters in their
original timelines with their happy
little families and
mobius riding a jet ski hopefully with
his memory as a loki intact because we
all know that he is
a loki that's just i'm on that train i
will
literally even if it doesn't end up
happening i will die of that hill
because i'm just you know crazy well
this is how it should have been
[Laughter]
i'm emailing feige right now but before
we continue on with the show we gotta
thank all those lovely people that make
inside marvel possible people like
mint mobile with big wireless providers
there's always a catch so when you hear
that mint mobile
offers premium wireless service starting
at just 15 bucks a month you're waiting
for the catch but guess what
there isn't one mint mobile's secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service
online only by cutting out retail stores
there's no crazy overhead costs that get
passed down to you through mystery fees
instead mitt just passes on those sweet
savings
directly to you so nice mint thank you
now here at new rockstars
philip switched to mint and he loves it
like he can't stop talking about it i
don't know why it's kind of weird
he kept his phone and his number and is
saving a bunch of money so maybe that's
why it talks about it and for people
looking for extra savings mipmobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month and all plans come with a
limited talk
and text and high speed data delivered
on the nation's
largest 5g network and if you're not 100
satisfied mint mobile has you covered
with their 7-day money-back guarantee so
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free
go to mintmobile.com marvel that's mint
mobile
dot com slash marvel cut your wireless
bill to 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com
marvel and we also want to thank the
folks at bluetooth the fine folks at
bluechu have a unique
online service that delivers the same
ingredients as viagra and cialis but
in chewable form at a fraction of the
cost bluetooth is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips and it ships right to
your door in a discreet package you sign
up at bluetooth.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers and
once you're approved
you receive your prescription within
days their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient
and strength and blue chew is chewable
just like it says in the name which is
great news for folks
that don't like swallowing pills so if
you could benefit from extra confidence
in the bedroom
blue chew can help and we have a special
deal for our listeners try bluetooth
free when use our promo code
inside marvel at checkout just pay five
dollars of shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code
inside marvel to receive your first
month for free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
show and then we of course have to thank
our friends at helix
you don't want to sleep on a mattress
designed for someone else even if that
other person is a variant of yourself
because
as we know variants are not exactly the
same they probably like some super firm
mattress because they're evil who likes
super firm mattresses not me
helix sleep has a quiz that matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress
for you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for plus
size
sleepers eric has a helix mattress and
he loves it the quiz matched him with a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that keeps cool
and that guy sleeps great even better
than his variant and the mattress ships
right to your door
for free so no need to go to a mattress
store so just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your dang life and helix is offering up
to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our audience at
helixsleep.com
inside marvel that's helixleep.com
inside marvel for up to 200
off and two free pillows that is two
more free pillows than you had before
so let's do it but anyway okay
jess second question of the day wait a
day minute
sylvie revealed that she's using the
name sylvie as an alias in that she knew
way earlier that she was adopted but
didn't learn her magic from
frigga so what is silvie's backstory
is that how we pronounce the mom's name
frigga yeah i think so
the worst part about reading comics is
knowing you're pronouncing
everything wrong and then you say it out
loud and i'm glad you read it first
um so what do you think sylvie's
backstory could be i
am still riding the train which might be
a little too
um that she's still related to him i
think there's a timeline
that and i know it's not comic book
adjacent
but we still haven't seen richard e
grant
and we haven't seen any of the other
loki variants other than
what we assume is sylvia and loki loki
um so i think one of them is her their
adult her adopted father
i think i like the storyline in the
comics where she um it was post ragnarok
and we did see that bit at the beginning
of
or um i think it was episode two when
loki's going through all the forms and
sees that right like
this killed a lot of people on asgard so
i think
she might have been one of those people
and um
she it was and then she got adopted by
loki and i feel like it would still
stand because
loki is probably just following odin's
footsteps of just being like i was
adopted
um in this world but in this universe
i'm going to adopt a child
myself um so i'm still holding on to
that
okay okay interesting i like that that's
a very
unique take i i like to think that like
like we were talking about earlier that
sylvie was fighting in the multiversal
war like we were talking about
um i think that sylvie was a soldier in
the multiversal war that didn't get her
mind wiped and
now she's just trying to free everybody
from the
winners of the war the timekeepers or
maybe the time twisters who knows
um and you know just basically
get the multiverse back to the way it
was before
they lost the war and the multiverse was
tied together
um it is interesting that she didn't
learn her magic from frigga though
because she seems pretty
really good at enchanting people like
very good at in chatty people well i
think that's
she learned it from her dad which is
loki
universe daddy i feel like they're not
gonna be working together not attack
team but if they do eventually fight
another loki those powers are not going
to be helpful at all because it's going
to be taught to her by her
adopted father that's loki but that loki
is more superior than our loki
it's impossible but i do
okay i don't think you remember that
loki cannot fight to save his life
in this in this episode he has been
doing pretty well
um but when he doesn't really have a lot
to work with he gets his ass kicked a
lot
it's true it's like he can fight well
sometimes but like when he's
over matched he's he's overmatched even
in the second episode i was like wow
sylvie's really kicking your butt i was
like you're doing a horrible job
knows how to fight that hallway
seen in the tva phenomenal that's what i
was
when they were on the um the train or
the
craft going to the ark this episode i
was like why can't loki fight like that
why can't you be more like sylvie loki
look at her and that's why i'm like also
like she is not a loki variant uh
because
no loki can do what she's doing but um
yeah i like the idea that that's what
she was she was in the multiversal war
gives her better
uh justification for wanting to take
down the tva um at first i was like i
think i pitched um
on rogue theory for the first episode
during the multiversal war this loki is
one that's like i want to be superior
i want to show that i'm the best loki
and my timeline was the best i should
have won
but i think this is her just being like
no they did wrong and i need to like
write this wrong and that's why that's
what makes her different from this loki
because loki
are loki is kind of selfish whereas
she's like no i'm going to kill them
because they deserve it um
but yeah i agree with you more than i
agree with me again
um go figure i do i do like your your
idea too like it's really it's really
fun it's really cool
deep okay so they can both still be
there they can both still be there i
just like the i just like her being a
part of loki
i like her being like having loki as a
dad in a different timeline
because then we're also getting more
humanized loki
i know i just want to see a daddy loki i
think that'd be really cool yeah well we
already have a variant of loki that has
a like a
wife and kids or a husband well one of
my favorite parts about this episode was
them getting into like even if it was
brief
just talking about like you're a prince
like you were probably beating women off
and men off with sticks
and it was just like yeah we don't talk
about like that he's still good looking
they still
god that even though he like was the god
of mischief
he's still this and i like to know that
backstory uh because in the
mcu he's just like a horrible villain
he's just annoying and we hate him but
it's like oh this is giving him
some sort of like humanity and i i need
to root for him in some form
so i need that in the script oh for sure
i i really loved how they did that in
the in the episode
like i used to like i before loki i'm
just like i don't really care about
logan this means a murderer you got all
those people in new york but now i'm
just like ah this man is damaged
he's dead oh yeah damn it's now i care
i like it and i hate it as someone that
always roots for the villain i'm like i
want him to just be
bad all the time but then i was like nah
like it's we're rooting for everyone's
bad in this
the show like not bad like they're bad
actors no
badass and they're like bad people in
the show so they probably each have
killed a minimum of 12 people
so what are we gonna do that makes uh
the writers are probably like what are
we gonna make
that's gonna make them wanna root for
the bad the bad guy
so they did a really good job of writing
this episode
i like how we started with what is
sylvie's past and now we're in
the writing of the episode well done
let's move on to the next question which
is
wait a damn minute what the hell even is
lamentous one
and what events caused this apocalyptic
planetary
collision hmm i'll go for it jess
no i want you to okay you can no you go
for it you go you go okay you go first
you go first
off okay okay okay so lamentus in the
comics is a planet on the outskirts of
the kree empire that only really appears
one time in i believe
annihilation conquest uh prologue
if i'm not mistaken but in that comic i
don't think that the planet gets
destroyed so
i'm wondering if this planetary
apocalyptic collision could have been
due to maybe
i don't know like a galactus baby that'd
be really fun
but like you know i feel like no i don't
think it's galactus because like
i don't think there would be any planets
left because he doesn't leave his plate
yeah uh he cleans off his plate that man
galactus does not leave any food on his
plate
he likes that thing he licks it clean oh
really quick i do think
you're still you're you're still valid
in
thinking that galactus could be there i
think the whole part of la mantis
is which think about it for every place
that we've seen so far in loki
we are gonna go back to these places so
far down the line in the mcu
they are just setting their shotgun in
like getting prepared
for everything to happen so i think we
are still gonna go to lomantis this can
open up the fantastic four to us so can
other things but this could open
fantastic four
this could put out more galactic stuff
this could open so many doors
and um like even going into well
maybe not eternals yet because eternals
is already done editing they're probably
not going to talk about laments
but there's so many things that are
happening here um and because
it was um there could be of millions of
cree there
that we just didn't see because they
this isn't about the cree right now this
is about loki so
there's so many ties that they're gonna
bring from la mancha so i think that
scene
or this entire episode is so important
to remember everything on that planet
because we're absolutely going back
there in the mcu
we are 100 going back i i you know
kevin feige doesn't do things by
accident i think that there is a high
chance that we could go to a past lament
i think you're right there i think
that's a really good
um point there um but also what's really
um
interesting is that like we said
lamentis is part of the kree empire in
the comics
and it could be part of the korean
empire in the mcu but we also see it
episode one in that animation
um the those cree fighting on this very
baron
type wasteland so maybe that was
lamentous but we didn't know it
until this episode oh honey
you guys hear that underline underline
it
be prepared okay so we're getting
we're getting set up for cree stuff with
lomantis
i mean like we have captain marvel well
too well the marvels anyway coming out
and like
they're that's probably going to deal
with more cree stuff so like you know
we're we're going to learn more and more
about this the cree history
oh my god because it's significant to
the marvel cosmic universe oh my god
i'm excited this hold on to this i'm so
excited for the
lomantis show there's there's a million
ways this could go
there's a lot of ways it can go and i'm
just excited for
it to be now in here because when it
showed up i was like
wait a minute and i typed it in and i
was like yeah this is the planet this is
like
everything happens here not everything
but it's just like
yeah i i really i always look for doors
for the fantastic four to show
up and so i'm constantly a big ass door
for the fantastic four let me tell you
what
because the council of reeds is coming
and those are all
variants i need it i know
there's so many ways for them to show up
i just can't wait to see what the way
they choose for them to show up is oh
god yes actually to wrap up what i was
saying before about the animation
we do see those little star type you
know structures
in the background of that animation but
we also see those stars on titan
which was also a doomed planet so maybe
there was something that happened like
via like the
i don't know the environment that like
caused
i don't know that planet up there to
crumble and i don't know
who knows but like there's there's all
sorts of his uh mystery behind
lamentous one so hopefully we'll learn
more about that as time goes on
um but yes what is our next question oh
wait a damn
minute loki just hinted that he's
bisexual
oh boy what might have been
some of loki's past hookups maybe
slain and not murdering this time maybe
who knows
he's still a god so yeah they like to
murder after any
fun occasion
this is a good question broke theory
um it has to be in the mcu it can't be
in the comics
because i was gonna say hella but then
also hello is his sister in the mcu yeah
like that'd be kind of game of thrones
really and what made a lot of money
game of thrones that's true that's true
incest cells
um i thought i have a poster on uh
at barnes noble did you i think i put
that up there
oh she-hulk 100
so not in like not in like a weird way
but i love she-hulk a lot and i think i
loved her a lot because
um she was there was like in the comics
she was hooking up with so many people
and i was like you're different
superheroes that i was like you go
girl i was like good for you i was like
you explore
you find out which one you like don't go
back to iron man he's really mean
but like but definitely i feel like they
could have crossed paths and she could
have been like
like let's like do the do and i would
for this because she is bigger and
stronger than you
and this is my thing um
this is my thing um i think that would
be fun
i think it'd be really cool if him and
fandral maybe
had like a thing when they were younger
baby i know that they aren't friends i
mean like
like i'm trying to think of of like as
guardians that he could have hooked up
with i'm like maybe fandral who knows
um i think that was zachary levi's kid
it is i'm looking up
i feel like they'd have a really
interesting dynamic and
you know it'd just be really fun okay i
get it um what about heimdall
loki probably hooked up with like you
know various historical figures and i
don't know yeah
just to get what he needs so like 100
maybe cleopatra maybe oh absolutely
hopefully not hitler
hopefully not terrible this is the god
of mischief
um i know the god of bishop has
standards he does oh he
it's still tom hiddleston at the end of
the day yes um he's still a suave
man definitely cleopatra definitely
cleopatra
those are like a perfect imagery because
it's like oh yeah
this is like old enough that we wouldn't
know and she probably wrote about it and
we just interpreted it as like
a god came from the sky as an eagle
and had sex with her and it was actually
loki but loki
he's a norse god he's a norse god of
course he he's he's everywhere he's
just putting his his norse wiener and
all sorts of players absolutely
also he definitely is probably more than
bisexual he
probably just does it he's just like i
just told you
in this one sentence that i hook up with
men and women
and we went yeah like that's what i'm
thinking too because like
realistically because he's a god because
he's like on a cosmic scale
he'd probably be pan if i'm assuming
because like i believe uh it was
announced that or revealed that
star-lord was pan and it makes sense for
star-lord because
he's just in the like he's just flying
around the universe and like meeting all
these aliens
of course like who cares like gender is
a construct yeah he literally is just
like
i don't what he's more he's more ashamed
of us
for putting him in a box anything
exactly
so yeah who knows bisexual pan either
way we're happy for you loki
hopefully you seriously go find you a
boo
whoever it is go find you a boot maybe
it'll make you more chill and less
stabby
but before i continue with the final
question of the day
we have to thank betterhelp for
sponsoring this video now we've all
experienced times
where something was interfering with our
happiness or preventing us from
achieving our goals
and better health is here to help they
assess your needs and match you with
your own
licensed professional therapist who you
can start communicating with in less
than 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online and they have a
broad range of expertise available for
clients worldwide just log into your
account anytime and schedule weekly
video or
phone sessions it's more affordable than
traditional online counseling and
financial aid is available betterhelp
wants you to start living a better life
today and check out the review section
of the website for testimonials from
folks who have gotten something from the
service
visit betterhelp.com marvel that's
better h-e-l-p-com
marvel and join the over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced
professional and here's a special offer
for the inside marvel audience
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
marvel all right for our last question
of the day jess wait a damn minute
now that we know that the timekeepers
lied about creating the tva agents
what the hell else are they lying about
like does rentslayer know that all of
this is a lie
okay i think ren slayer knows it's a lie
i feel like it's impossible
could also be me being crazy impossible
to work that closely with them and not
know it
also like i i'm holding on to that
little bit of piece where
uh owen wilson was like you know some of
those trophies are like my trophies and
she's like yeah but they're my missions
it's like i feel like she knows she
knows something she knows something
i don't think she's completely not in
the know she's so in control of stuff
also what if plot twist mobius already
knew he's a variant
he was just lying to loki i i think that
that could be the case like if if mobius
is another loki variant
i think that this could just be a really
long con because
loki's are really good at lying as you
can see in this episode
like freaking both loki and sylvie were
just lying just straight up and they
were very good
so good but what else do you think the
tva could be lying about like could the
whole
sacred timeline thing be a bunch of
like what what the hell are
they doing oh
i think the sacred timeline is a bunch
of it's not
it's not needed it's not needed but i
think that i i always let they go over
my head because i'm just like yeah i
guess there has to be some type of
authority
but i don't think there really needs to
be um even though they were there since
the dawn of time it's still just like or
so they say
or so they or something they say they
could be lying about that too
true oh my god they absolutely you can
everything we we've been told about loki
so far in regards to the tva could have
just been
alive you are i'm thinking too inside
the box and you're coming outside the
box and telling me
like truth if you think about it like
you know the ancient one
and goes into the concept of the
multiverse in doctor strange one and we
do meet dormammu
who exists in a completely different
universe like so we've already
traveled the multiverse in the mcu
technically so
if the mult if the timekeepers were
around since the beginning of time and
they smushed the timeline together
how is multiverse travel still possible
so it's just like yeah
tba real real talk real question
on what level is the eternals and the
tva
or the timekeepers where do they meet um
because power level yeah and a power
level who was there
watch our latest big question because
when we get into that
i'm sorry i don't need to play but no no
you should you should
because i'm like what if the tva has to
initiate
the um the disasters that are happening
um in order to keep things aligned but
then i'm also like
wouldn't the eternal stop that and when
the eternals know of the tva
but is the tba higher than the god well
like in terms of power rankings the tva
as far as we know anyway given the
knowledge that we know yeah
given the tva seems to be more powerful
than
most people in the universe in in the
universes or timelines that they go into
i like the fact that you brought the
eternals because if the tva is going
around to these various planets and
interacting with the people they have to
interact with some eternals at some
point and some eternals
on different planets have to become
variants because
you never know what you're going to do
to become a variant you know you could
be like to work
and then you're you're a variant so like
you know
tva agents have had to logically face
off against eternals in the past so
okay true so if they're
they seem to be going fine i think that
tva agents are
capable of overpowering pretty much
anybody and slapping handcuffs on them
okay um which is kind of nuts diesel
power
well they're obviously lying about that
i don't
know what they're lying about i think
they're lying about who's been here
first
the chicken or the egg i think they're
lying about the timeline of themselves
also i there has to be more
miss minutes though she's your girl she
was really underplaying the multiversal
war
um so i think there's a lot i don't
think it's a lie because they didn't
really get into it
but they're keeping secrets about the
multiversal world which is
war multiversal war
which i think also aligns with your
theory that everyone
is from the mer they're slaves from the
multiversal war and they're forced to
work in the tva
um so they're not really lying about
that it's more so they're stretching the
truth
but um no i think they exaggerated truth
they are laying on a hoax also we have
to see them
but what if we never see them i will be
really upset if the timekeepers are fake
um whatever you don't see them judging
by c20 she gave
silvia the location of the time but she
just said it's the golden elevator
we don't know what's up the golden
elevator this is true she did
what if ren's layer just ends up being
whatever you know what
you never know every our entire reality
has been questioned with this episode
because everything that tva told us
is basically we can't say it's well you
weren't supposed to trust them in the
first place they're a big prison
and plus yeah it is big prison it's just
prison it's just prison we're not
supposed to trust them
like prison loves to make profit i hope
our prison viewership is like yeah
people are like wow all they talk about
is prison
prison you rock stars pro prison all
right
i'm not po prison i'm not pro prison
appropriate no we're definitely not
president okay side note we didn't get
into it
it wasn't a question on here but i want
to add that
loki's powers in this episode were so
crazy
and i think it's because he took a
freaking stone
i took the title you saw that too right
the building you saw that building right
yo the building went reverse i was like
that's doctor strange what
that doctor strange what as soon as he
did it but this ain't normal
normal he just reversed it he didn't
because i was like he didn't even
blow it away it went back he took the
time exactly that's the time stone
that's
their little like hint yeah he had the
time so he had it the whole time and he
used it but you didn't know that he used
it
it's hella dr strange i was way i was
like
i was like that wasn't even he reversed
it i was like i was like you've never
done that before loki like that would
have come in handy
multiple times in the past he took a
paper weight he took one of
the times paperweight oh my which
honestly i would do the exact same thing
as soon as i
wanted to evidence 12 stones
[Laughter]
jessica stop i can't
this song's too good oh it's just so
good uh
also soundtrack for loki is very great
as well
phenomenal but anyways that is it for
this episode of inside marvel i want to
thank jess for joining me this episode
and
you know substituting for eric she's
amazing you can follow her
at lulu clemens wherever she is and you
can follow me at mastertainment wherever
i am but most importantly eric's
breakdown of episode 3
of loki will be on the channel on friday
so keep an eye out for that because
my boy eric knows how to break things
down like a mother dang that man is
a breakdown connoisseur so please watch
out for that but yes
make sure to subscribe to new rockstars
and hit that notification bell so you
can get notifications whenever we upload
a new video
and uh take it easy
[Music]
you